let's say someone walks up to you on the
street and says
to you
divided by
50 divided by 5 is equal to blank
is equal to blank how can you think
about this as a multiplication problem
well whatever blank is whatever blank is
if you multiply it by 5
if you multiply by 5
you should get 50. you should get 50.
you should get 50. so one way of
thinking about it you could say what
times 5
is 50
well 10 times 5 is 50.
10 times 5 is 50 so 50 divided by 5 is
going to be
10. hopefully you see the relationship
here 50 divided by 5 is 10 then 10 times
5 is 50. 10 times 5
is 50. and you could do it the other way
around
what is 50
divided by 10 going to be
50 divided by 10
well that's going to be equal to 5.
50 divided by 10 is going to be equal to
5. how do i know that well 5
times 10
5 times 10 5 times 10 is equal to 50
is equal
to 50.
so let's keep thinking about this if
someone walked up to the street again
and said
blank
divided by
blank divided by 2
is equal to
9 how would you figure out what blank is
something divided by 2 is equal to 9.
well one way to think about it and if we
just follow here if you said 50 divided
by 5 is 10 you could say 10 times 5 is
50. so right over here we could say well
times
9 times 2
must be equal to blank
must be equal to our blank well we know
what 9 times 2 is that is 18. so this
must be 18. 18 divided by 2 is 9. and
that's really say describing how 18 2
and 9 relate to each other two nines is
eighteen or nine twos is eighteen or if
i were to divide eighteen into two
groups each group would have nine or if
i were to divide into groups of two you
would have nine groups anyway you look
at it eighteen divided by two is nine
nine times two is 18. let's do one more
of these so someone walks up to you on
the street and tells you
and tells you that 12
divided by
divided by blank
twelve divided by blank
is equal to three
what is blank going to be
well one way to think about this is
three times blank is going to be equal
to twelve
three
times blank
three times this unknown number is going
to be equal to twelve
and three times what is equal to twelve
well three times 4
is equal to 12 so 12 divided by 4
is equal to 3.